for over a half a century the caravan
salon in Dusseldorf has been the perfect
place to check out all the latest trends
and camping the leading trade fair for
motorhomes and caravans drew a record
200,000 visitors this year young people
in particular seem to have rediscovered
the joys of camping Delmonico's affair
head of Germany's Caravan Industry
Association says a lot of young families
came and a considerable number but a new
Caravan the increase in sales was way
above the association's own expectations
doctors over headphones of iron and
positive novato this year's Caravan
salon had more exhibition space than
ever offering a dizzying array of
options from compact and practical
camper vans to the heights of luxury
visitors to the trade fair would be
well-advised to make up their minds
beforehand about what it is they're
looking for
whether it's a romantic holiday for two
or something with space for the whole
family check out your finances too if
you know what you want the choice is
less overwhelming this man's looking
specifically for an affordable campervan
based on a box van but he wants to try
some out first so he's going to inquire
about options for renting vehicles the
classic VW transporter is still one of
the leading camper vans despite its
relatively high price the California
version is the most popular choice and
retains its value on the second-hand
market the basic level Beach trim comes
with a bed but no kitchen crisis in
Germany start at forty-two thousand
euros the Carmen colibri 499 from Reno
is a shade cheaper at 41,000 euros it
comes with a kitchen and refrigerator
the basic version has an 88 kilowatt
engine and practical features like
cruise control
the new personal camps different suit
when is only a prototype at this stage
but due to go on sale next year the
focus here is on flexibility the kitchen
is included but can be removed if
desired turning the campervan into a
normal van with seven seats prices for
the 70 kilowatt basic version start at
thirty-eight thousand euros
or you could go for this more Spartan
alternative and save another 10,000
euros it includes bed auxiliary heating
cooler box cruise control rear view
camera and hands-free communication the
trade fair price for this Alpine camper
based on the Nissan nv200 was just 28
thousand euros but there's a yet more
basic version still the cuckoo camping
box it comes in various sizes and can
fit into practically any box type van
turning it instantaneously into a mini
camper van at the other end of the
spectrum the 12 metre long vario perfect
offers space and luxury galore a neat
kilowatt diesel generator provides
electricity and there's 600 liters of
fresh water onboard the whole thing will
set you back about 1.2 million euros and
that doesn't include the mercedes 300sl
roadster in the rear garage
space and luxury is one thing but a
growing number of customers also want
undiminished connectivity on holiday cuz
next this man says his next camper van
needs to have Wi-Fi and solar panels so
that he can work that way the children
can enjoy the whole summer holiday
traveling and not notice if their
parents work for two or three hours a
day six moment when I fail Ascanio Finn
the edematous white Western on top all
right if you have six hundred eighty
thousand euros to spare you might want
to go for the ultimate experience of
freedom with the action mobile here you
can go off-road or wherever you want it
comes with a 397 kilowatt engine and a
600 liter diesel tank so you can tour
through the wilds for as long as you
want without running out of fuel or
having to forgo any of those creature
comforts action mobil CEO stephan vet
says the RV offers everything you could
find at home including an induction
cooktop a washing machine and an
electric oven all the appliances are
good quality makes it has a huge battery
capacity which you could live from four
days without necessarily having to drive
to Tate in an auto laden cotton energy
efficiency is key for undertaking
lengthy off road trips the Bliss is
completely self-sufficient thanks to the
solar panels on the roof with a storage
capacity of 400 amp hours you could
experience a three-day solar eclipse and
still not have to worry about using the
oven or air conditioning
you